all right having a backup town and d-roc
and I decided that we don't need to film
this one meeting so the Iraq he took
notes all day what the hell was
interesting today go I remember them
super well as a matter of fact is it
possible that my first laptop computer
came from your dad
I'm almost positive that the laptop that
your dad got me which had a cd-rom which
was like insane at the time was the
computer that I used to watch
winelibrary.com actually you know what
why don't you guys introduce yourself I
wanna get this fix what's been happening
all day long I'll be right back buddy
I've been in like ten meetings in a row
now we're like either it takes ten
minutes or they can't even get to the
Apple TV HDMI setup do we like and now I
just hold like Lindsey's like well my
computer doesn't work because we haven't
updated yet there's that another thing
what's a couple quick questions what's
going on and then - can we get hdmi
cables in all these rooms like what like
it just seems like seriously like I'm
wasting ten fifteen seven nine minutes
in every meeting Adventureland
so is it room is there room and then
airplay the separate issue what's the
punchline we got to get people updated
that are on anything before
El Capitan which was last year's release
I need to get up to have the means to do
that it's just
so do you guys is this [ __ ] them not
wanting to waste our 20 minutes do they
can they do it you have to do it like
what's help me help you I can make them
all do it like I can like you know what
I mean like help me help
here's what here's what I like here's
what I like let's do this send me an
email with your plan but here's the
bottom line I can make them all deucey I
will make them do it whatever they have
to do and then I need you to address
fast with no financial thoughts in mind
the rooms that are working cool it's
just when you think of it at my level
we're losing more money like I'm losing
pitches do you know what I mean
like I don't care what it takes like I
don't care what else is going on we're
just losing so whether we have to buy it
and needs approval approved whether it's
you've got something else tell me what
that is and I'll tell you that you don't
have to do that now if you're like the
security of the whole company is online
then I'll say yes do that you like help
me help me help you in the next 24 hours
all right the other things like I would
have a full set I would have a full
media intern for example that same
intern or two by the way I mean again if
it's free worth taking a credit or
minimum wage there's just a lot of
people smart enough to know that getting
close to you like that it works you know
the other thing is one of them's be
booking podcasters for you I mean when
you're doing everything you're dead like
I did it two and a half years ago I was
there all by myself doing all that yeah
so so right so it's hard but when other
people are doing it a lot more can be
done it takes time to to find the right
cadence but we've created a service for
that but it's not going to be affordable
for most people I want you to extract
the pieces from it and then go an
executor scale scale and everybody
thinks scale is technology and that's
what everybody's talking about scale
comes of people scale comes in people as
well and it's a version that has been
tried and true long before the internet
came along and so I think most of us are
grossly under estimating the impact of
another
being on what they're trying to
accomplish and what you could be doing
for them we're all looking for the
algorithm and big data and the tech and
the app that's gonna scale it you know
there's nothing that scales to
tried-and-true do you understand like if
you're actually getting engage with your
community there's no algorithm you can
do that you think that works but it
doesn't because the essence behind it
isn't actually happening
you can only scale so far the human part
of it is an absolute must scale is a
part of it
both both so my name is John Troutman
worked with Gary for seven years at
vaynermedia for about four and I work
really closely with him leadership team
kind of support and different special
projects and initiatives that they're
focused on previously came from the wine
industry I'd worked with Gary a lot on
his personal brand and kind of wine
content side of things at a small wine
social network and then eventually
worked with him and daily grape which
was his his wine out which frankly was
kind of ahead of its time a lot of
mobile video content that people are now
watching right now and then from there I
kind of pimped it over and came to
vaynermedia I think like one of the the
biggest things that I've come to realize
as we've grown so quickly is is that you
can't be hands-on with everything like
it's kind of like the analogy that Gary
uses like clouds and dirt and it's
knowing when to be really hands-on and
micromanage something versus like what
are the things that you should
empowering what leaders go out and do on
their own I think that's something that
I've really learned a lot from him over
the years is like there are certain
things that you definitely want to get
your hands dirty with and be super
involved with especially when the stakes
are high there's other things that like
frankly as you scale and grow a business
but you got to allow other people to
kind of take on and run with you know
this is without a doubt ten of the most
exciting that's my life
I've come here really just to tell you
about myself my hospital and my company
I'm not asking you to invest today I
just want to get to know ya creating the
content I'm I believe in this demo I
mean believe in it the most and believe
you
which is why get over here dear ox the
40,000 of you that do it every day and
wondering why he gets in either I
believe the person is smart enough to
play a 20 year marathon or do it or I
think all the people say they're gonna
buy me lunch and that's worth my hour or
rather much so I genuinely believe you
which is what how we even got here in a
world where I only do this five ten
eight times a year so my name is Zach
Dixon from New Orleans - born in New
Orleans live there now spend the last
five years in New York the last tooth
hustling on players lounge love this and
yeah I mean I reached out to Gary in
July and I emailed him and I said how
many days in a row was the subject line
and then the next line and the the email
body was would it take for me to email
you in a row before I could get you to
respond then I emailed the begin on day
2 I told him a little bit more about
myself and then I emailed him again on
day three and he responded yeah and by
the way there are thousands of people
that are still doing it and will never
get the meeting there are thousands of
people doing that like perseverance
there's only one part of the equation
actually believing that that person is
playing a forty-year game or it's a good
con context creator the key of the key
moment for you in your career because I
can do that too and so can a lot of
other people believe it or not is can
you back that sizzle it's everything you
know I believe you in that part we're
sitting here
the next part matters so [ __ ] much
and the number one thing I'm gonna tell
you the only thing I'm gonna tell you
because I think you're gonna figure it
all out you don't leave me this is if
you ever think that the steak is not
coming together properly over
communicate to the people that bought
into your sizzle
now peaceful yes you got it if it's not
gonna pan out when you're jamming with
me and Strauss and all these people
we've all lost to be smart about how you
navigate that yeah too many people are
great to get in the room are destined to
actually win on their second or third or
fourth thing when losing in their first
thing they handle it so poorly that they
lose so much of what they a member you
see remote yeah America hates the cover
up
so the Iraq he took notes all day what
the hell was interesting today go
[Music]